Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先快速告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. with Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。
Thank you for listening as ever and thank you for all of your super kind comments. They're really gratefully received. I'd really love any audio testimonials for the podcast itself or any of the books um just so that i know that you're really enjoying what you're listening to and i'd really love to have any audio testimonials you might be willing to leave me for the podcast itself for more information how to do that, go to www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk forward slash podcast or the link will be there in the show notes for you too.
一如既往，感谢大家的收听，也感谢你们所有超级友善的评论。我非常感激。我真的很希望能收到关于播客本身或我所著书籍的音频感言，这样我就能知道你们是否真的喜欢所听的内容。如果你愿意为播客留下音频感言，我将不胜感激。欲了解更多操作信息，请访问 www.goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk/podcast，或者查看节目说明中的链接。
This is all about collaboration. And another great piece of collaboration is when we work work as part of multidisciplinary teams also called MDTs and being part of an MDT and having had MDT experience is something which is really useful for any aspiring psychologist and it's something that often crops up you know for assistant psychologist interviews. I learned my trade in working in multidisciplinary teams when I was at St Andrews Healthcare. That was the first MDT team that I had been part of. And I was so fortunate that I'd been around such highly skilled and competent, caring, kind team members. And I learned a great deal from them. And they were, you know, kind and patient towards me as I developed my stripes as an aspiring psychologist too. So when I was thinking about reaching out to have a psychiatrist on the podcast,
这期节目是关于协作的。另一个伟大的协作形式是我们作为多学科团队（MDT）的一部分进行工作。成为MDT的一员并拥有MDT经验，对于任何有抱负的心理学家来说都非常有益，而且这在助理心理学家的面试中经常被问到。我在圣安德鲁斯医疗中心（St Andrews Healthcare）工作时学会了如何在多学科团队中工作。那是我参与的第一个MDT团队。我非常幸运，身边有如此高技能、能干、充满关怀和友善的团队成员。我从他们身上学到了很多。在我作为一名有抱负的心理学家不断成长时，他们对我既友善又耐心。所以，当我在考虑邀请一位精神科医生参加播客时，
my first thoughts were of a psychiatrist that I had worked with as an aspiring psychologist and so I was brave and I reached out and asked him if he would be willing to come along and record an episode for us and he was so kind and gracious and said that he would love to. So I am thrilled to introduce you to someone I knew as a doctor. And since I have moved on to past years new, he has gone on to become a professor. So you're going to be listening to me chatting with Professor Graham Yorston, who is a consultant psychiatrist. And today's episode is all about working with MDTs, but also about practical ways to manage risk as well, which is something that psychiatrists are really good at and something that I learned a lot from my time
我首先想到的是我作为助理心理学家时曾共事过的一位精神科医生。于是我鼓起勇气联系了他，询问他是否愿意来录制一期节目，他非常友善且大度地答应了。所以我非常激动地向大家介绍我曾经称呼为“医生”的那位嘉宾。自从我离开那里去往新的领域后，他已经成为了一名教授。接下来你们将听到我与格雷厄姆·约斯顿教授（Professor Graham Yorston）的对话，他是一位精神科顾问医生。今天的节目是关于与MDT合作，以及管理风险的实用方法，这是精神科医生非常擅长的领域，也是我在圣安德鲁斯工作期间学到很多东西的地方。
working at St Andrews. I hope you find this episode really useful. And as ever, we welcome any comments, any questions. You can watch this on YouTube, but it is audio only. So you'll just have lots of nice pictures to look at if you're watching on YouTube. If you're listening on Apple Podcasts, please do rate and review. Be gratefully received. So yeah, I hope you find this episode useful. So welcome along. I just want to say hi and welcome our guest, Professor Graham Yorston. I'll let you introduce yourself. Hi, yes, I'm Graham Yorston. I am a forensic neuropsychiatrist. So I've had a wide range of experience in different areas of psychiatry, worked in different hospitals around the country, in Scotland and England, and different levels of
希望你们觉得这期节目非常有用。一如既往，欢迎大家提出意见和问题。你们可以在YouTube上观看，但这只是音频内容，所以如果你们在YouTube上观看，只会看到一些精美的图片。如果你是在Apple Podcasts上收听，请务必评分和评论，我将不胜感激。那么，希望你们觉得这期节目有用。欢迎收听。我想先打个招呼，欢迎我们的嘉宾格雷厄姆·约斯顿教授。请你自我介绍一下。你好，是的，我是格雷厄姆·约斯顿。我是一名法医神经精神科医生。我在精神病学的不同领域拥有广泛的经验，曾在全国各地的不同医院工作，包括苏格兰和英格兰，以及不同级别的
security. So from high secure, medium secure, low secure and currently working in a rehab setting in Northampton. Wonderful, thank you so much for joining us. Our paths first crossed when I was an assistant psychologist so when I was looking at how to thicken the dialogue of psychiatry and psychology. You were the first person I thought of, but I am a little bit daunted to have you here. I can't imagine why you'd be daunted. No, I think, you know, assistant psychologists do perform a really important part of MDTs. And I think it is difficult because, you know, particularly if you're a brand new assistant psychologist, you're quite young and everybody else in the team is usually a bit older and they may have years and years of experience. But there's absolutely nothing to be daunted by. Most people in MDTs are very nice and very welcoming.
安全设施。从高安全、中安全、低安全级别，目前在北安普顿的一家康复机构工作。太棒了，非常感谢你的加入。我们的交集始于我担任助理心理学家的时候，当时我正在研究如何加深精神病学与心理学之间的对话。你是我第一个想到的人，但我邀请你时感到有点忐忑。我无法想象你为什么要忐忑。不，我认为，你知道，助理心理学家在MDT中发挥着非常重要的作用。而且我认为这很困难，因为，你知道，特别是如果你是一名刚入行的助理心理学家，你还很年轻，而团队中的其他人通常年纪稍大，他们可能拥有多年的临床经验。但完全没有什么可忐忑的。MDT中的大多数人都非常友善且热情。
They certainly are. And I always felt very welcome in the teams when I worked with you so thank you um I do remember you didn't really like my hair accessories at the time and you had a very valid very bad point don't you remember I had some sort of crazy chopsticks in my hair and you were like someone could easily poke you in the eye with those I was like hmm yes you may be right gosh I think the Alzheimer's must be catching up with me. I don't actually remember that. No, you mentioned it. Yeah, I mean, it's the kind of important issue of kind of risk awareness
他们确实如此。当我和你共事时，我总是感到非常受欢迎，所以谢谢你。嗯，我记得当时你不太喜欢我的发饰，而且你提出了一个非常有效且糟糕的观点。你不记得了吗？我当时在头发上插了一些奇怪的筷子，你说有人很容易用那些东西戳到我的眼睛。我说：“嗯，是的，你说得对。”天哪，我想一定是阿尔茨海默症找上我了，我其实不记得那件事了。不，你提到了。是的，我的意思是，这涉及到一个关于风险意识的重要问题，
that somebody right at the start of their career just may not think about things like that that could be used as a potential weapon in a secure unit where people have a history of serious violence. Absolutely. I did give it back to you, though. I did say, well, they could whip the pen out of your pocket as well, Dr. Yorston. And you were like, yeah, but then I'd know they'd done that. You wouldn't know if they're behind you. And I was like, all right, you're totally right. I never wore them again to work by the way very sensible i did take a pen in and you're absolutely right so pens are a potential uh weapon and in some of the the most uh acute wards in high secure hospitals uh you have to leave your pens in store and you are only allowed to use those little tiny
即一个职业生涯刚开始的人可能根本不会想到，在那些有严重暴力史的人员所在的封闭单位里，这些东西可能会被用作潜在的武器。绝对是这样。不过我确实把它还给你了，我说：“好吧，他们也可以从你的口袋里掏出钢笔，约斯顿医生。”你当时说：“是的，但那样我就知道他们做了什么。如果你背对着他们，你就不会知道。”我说：“好吧，你是完全正确的。”顺便说一句，我再也没有戴过它们去上班。非常明智。我确实带了一支笔进去，你是完全正确的，所以钢笔是潜在的武器。在一些高安全医院最急性的病房里，你必须把笔存放在储物柜里，只允许使用那种小小的、
stubby pens that you know that kind of three or four inches long like you steal from asda not asda argos that's the ones we don't we don't condone stealing here they've switched them to pencils now you know you can still hurt someone seriously with a pencil and you know uh particularly if it's a really sharp pencil you can do a lot of damage um and certainly in one of the hospitals that i worked at um it was damaged to people's eyes that were the um was the kind of preferred doesn't sound the right quite quite the right word but um it was it was a not uncommon form of attack was to stab people in the eye with a pen or a pencil. So you're absolutely right to highlight the risk
粗短的笔，你知道那种三四英寸长的，就像你从Argos偷来的那种——不是Asda，是Argos。我们不纵容偷窃行为。他们现在把笔换成了铅笔，你知道，你仍然可以用铅笔严重伤害别人，你知道，特别是如果铅笔非常尖的话，你可以造成很大的伤害。当然，在我工作过的一家医院里，对人们眼睛的伤害是……这听起来可能不是最合适的词，但那是一种并不罕见的攻击形式，就是用钢笔或铅笔刺伤人们的眼睛。所以你强调我戴筷子上班的风险是完全正确的。所以谢谢你。但这确实是一个需要考虑的重要领域，不是吗？当我们处理风险时，甚至不是在法医服务部门工作时，你知道，在任何我们工作的环境中，即使是我们认为非常了解的人，也可能存在风险。
of me wearing chopsticks to work. So thank you for that. But it's an important area to consider, isn't it? When we're working with risk, especially not even when we're working in forensic services, you know, any setting we're working in, even someone we think we know really well could potentially be risky. Yeah, I think this is a really important point to get across. If you're working in a high secure hospital, then you're going to get a lot of induction about risk and you're going to be well aware that you're dealing with people who could pose a risk to you. But if you're working in an outpatient setting or an acute psychiatry inpatient setting, then that's the first point of contact that people will have with mental health services. So some of those people who do eventually end up in high secure hospital
是的，我认为这是一个非常重要的观点。如果你在高安全医院工作，你会接受很多关于风险的入职培训，你会非常清楚你正在处理的人可能会对你构成风险。但如果你在门诊或急性精神科住院部工作，那么这就是人们与心理健康服务机构的第一次接触。所以，那些最终进入高安全医院的人，
have started in those services. So they might have all those aggressive tendencies. They just haven't been, no one knows about them yet. So you have to at least be aware of the potential for aggression and make sure that you're safe, make sure that you can get out of an interview room and not put yourself at risk in any way. Absolutely. I still remember setting up the room quite carefully I vividly
有些是从这些服务机构开始的。所以他们可能拥有所有那些攻击性倾向，只是还没有人知道。所以你至少要意识到攻击的可能性，并确保你是安全的，确保你可以离开面试室，并且不会以任何方式让自己处于危险之中。绝对是这样。我仍然记得非常小心地布置房间。我生动地
remember you dragging chairs around to make sure that you know you were going to be able to get out of rooms and the staff were if we needed to and that there were enough escorts or people trained in restraint when we were all trained in restraint weren't we but to be able to you know have the best possible outcome from any situation, it's about thinking in advance, isn't it? And planning for the worst, preparing for the worst and hoping it won't happen. Definitely, yes. And I think, so, you know, you've got to stay in control if you are in a hospital or any kind of healthcare setting of getting the room positioned before the person
记得你拖动椅子，以确保你知道如果需要的话，你能够离开房间，而且如果有足够的护送人员或受过约束训练的人员——我们当时都受过约束训练，不是吗？但为了能够从任何情况中获得最好的结果，关键在于提前思考，为最坏的情况做计划，为最坏的情况做准备，并希望它不会发生。当然，是的。我认为，你知道，如果你在医院或任何类型的医疗保健环境中，你必须保持控制，在人进来之前把房间布置好。
comes in. Always looks a bit strange if you're moving furniture around once they're in. But, you know, get yourself so that you are closest to the door. And I have done that time and time again, all throughout my career. Even in children's services, I was always closest to the door because I've learned from you and from our late colleague Dr Wood how to you know how to ensure that your safety and the patient's safety is optimized. Yeah these are very important lessons I'm glad that I'm surprised that I was the first person to tell you about that but but it is those are important lessons that you know get into a good habit early in your career and always stick with it it'll just become second nature then you won't think about it definitely and one of my top tips that I learned was popular pop your diary on
如果他们在里面时你还在移动家具，总是看起来有点奇怪。但是，你知道，让自己处于离门最近的位置。在我的整个职业生涯中，我一次又一次地这样做。即使在儿童服务部门，我也总是离门最近，因为我从你和我们已故的同事伍德医生（Dr Wood）那里学到了如何确保你自己的安全和病人的安全得到优化。是的，这些是非常重要的教训。我很高兴，但我很惊讶我是第一个告诉你这些的人，但这些确实是重要的教训，让你在职业生涯早期养成良好的习惯，并始终坚持下去，这就会成为第二天性，你甚至不会去想它。绝对是这样。我学到的顶级技巧之一就是，当你去接病人时，把你的日记本放在
your chair when you go and get the patient so they can't sit in your chair and it's all it's quite interesting when they try to or they give you your diary back and then you have to say I'm'm gonna see it there um it's a test of kind of social norms as well that sounds an interesting one I don't think you learned that one from me uh because I that's a really good uh tip actually I'd have to remember that one myself I can I have I have used useful um strategies as well um you also taught me um something um that you may not know that you taught me but I use every day so I often used to do um the notes um in our ward round sessions but sometimes you would do it and you were doing something on the computer and I thought how did he do that and you introduced
你的椅子上，这样他们就不能坐在你的椅子上了。当他们试图坐下或者把日记本还给你时，这很有趣，然后你不得不说：“我要坐那里。”这也是对社会规范的一种测试。这听起来很有趣，我不认为你是从我这里学到的，因为这实际上是一个非常好的技巧，我自己也得记住这一点。我也有过有用的策略。你还教过我一些你可能不知道你教过我的东西，但我每天都在用。我经常在查房时做记录，但有时你会做，你在电脑上做一些事情，我想：“他是怎么做到的？”你向我介绍了使用删除键来删除已经输入的文本，只需按住它，而在此之前，我是一个字一个字地按退格键。所以每次我这样做时，我都会想到你。天哪，我教别人IT知识？这听起来极不可能，但我相信你。你得告诉你孩子们，他们会很高兴的。是的，在过去，我是一个相对较新的信息技术采用者，但现在我觉得自己像个恐龙，因为一切对我来说发展得太快了。好吧，在我和删除键的关系上，你是一位影响者。所以谢谢你。你在职业生涯中是否从某个随机来源学到过什么非常有用的东西，
me to using the delete button to delete text that you've already typed just to hold your finger on it whereas before I met you I was backspacing every every single thing so every time I do that I do think of you. Good heavens me teaching someone that IT that sounds highly improbable but I'll take your word for it. You'll have to tell your children and they'll be delighted. Yeah back in the day I you know I was I was a relatively new adopter of information technology, but I feel like a dinosaur nowadays because it's all moving way too fast for me. Well, you were an influencer when it came to me and the delete key. So thank you. Have you learned anything along your career from a random source that's been really useful
或者你能想到什么你认为“这对我很重要”或者“我一直都在用它”，而你在当时并不一定知道你会学到它？是的，我的意思是，我认为你知道，作为一名医生，培训在很大程度上是一种学徒制。所以，你知道，显然你的很多事实和知识来自书籍、论文之类的东西，但实际上如何与人打交道、如何接近人、如何与团队成员互动，很大程度上是关于观察，你知道，身处团队中，观察这些团队是如何互动的，然后说：“是的，我喜欢这个人管理他或她的团队的方式，这就是我想要成为的样子。”同样地，
or something that you can think of that you think, well that was that was really important for me or I use that all the time and you wouldn't necessarily have known that you were planning to learn it at the time yes I mean I think you know training as as a doctor is very much an apprenticeship so you know obviously a lot of your your facts your knowledge it comes from books and papers and things but actually how to deal with with people how to approach people how to interact with team members is very much um about seeing you know being in teams observing how those teams interact and then going yeah i like the way this person is is uh running you know his or her team and that's how I would want to be and equally um seeing people doing it not so well
看到人们做得不是那么好，或者过于正式等等，我会想：“是的，我不想那样做。”是的，绝对是这样。而且在团队中如何定位自己非常重要，不是吗？绝对是这样。我认为这是助理心理学家的关键问题之一，因为你进入一个团队，你可能不太了解人们，团队可能非常成熟，已经运行多年，关系良好。可能有人拥有多年的临床经验。而在你第一天上班时，你走进查房，看到一片你不认识的面孔。
uh and being a little bit too formal or whatever it might be I'm thinking yeah that doesn't I don't want to do it that way yeah absolutely and how to position yourself in teams can be so important can't it definitely I think this is one of the key issues for for assistant psychologists because you're coming into a team you probably don't know people very well the team may be very established and have been going along for years, good relationships. There might be people with years and years of clinical experience. And on your first day, you go into this ward round and see the sea of faces that you don't know.
你如何融入那个团队？你做什么？你是做一个外向的人，然后以最大的音量介绍自己吗？还是你只是坐在后排，非常温顺，几乎不说话？我认为，要融入那个团队并意识到这需要努力和工作是非常困难的。我认为思考这一点很重要。我认为你越是有意识地去思考“我该怎么做？”，结果就越可能更好。而且每个团队都是不同的。
How do you fit into that team? What do you do? Do you be a big personality and kind of, you know, introduce yourself at full volume? Or do you kind of just sit in the back row and be very meek and mild and hardly say a thing? And it's very difficult, I think, to break into that team and to be aware that that's, you know, that requires effort and work. And thinking about, I think, is important. I think the more that you make a conscious effort to think about, well, how am I going to do this? You know, the better it's likely to be. And every team is going to be different.
所以，正如我所说，我在大量不同的环境中工作过，医疗模式在团队中占主导地位的程度各不相同，因此心理学对这些团队的投入是绝对不可或缺的还是稍微边缘化的，也会有所不同。我会说，作为一名加入团队的新助理心理学家，倾听，相对安静地观察。你不想完全默默无闻，但是，你知道，不要一上来就表现出强烈的个性和强烈的观点，因为人们只会看着你，心想：“这个人是谁？”
So, as I say, you know, I've worked in a huge number of different environments, and the extent to which the medical model is dominant varies between teams, and therefore the extent to which psychological input into those teams is going to be absolutely integral or slightly peripheral is also going to vary. And I would say, you know, as a new AP joining a team, listen, observe relatively quietly. You don't want to be completely anonymous, but, you know, don't go in with a big personality and big opinions straight off because people are just going to look at you and think, who is this person?
所以，你知道，观察，对团队有帮助。所以我一直做的一件事是偶尔煮咖啡，这样团队里的每个人都是轮值的一部分。没有人高高在上到不去为其他人煮咖啡，这有助于建立联系。所以同样，取决于MDT会议是如何组织的，通常病人会被带进这些会议，我认为如果你作为助理心理学家从一开始就说：“哦，你知道，你想让我去接病人吗？”而不是依赖某一个人去做，这效果非常好。而且我认为理解心理学对团队的投入模式是什么也很重要。这是一种完全整合的方法吗？你每周都参加每一次MDT会议或查房吗？每一次CPA，你都在那个病房，那是你的病房吗？还是更像是一种转诊模式？如果是转诊模式，你只是偶尔参加，那么要求转诊是可以的。但如果你是整合团队的一部分，那么最糟糕的事情就是，当团队里有人说“如果能在这个问题上得到心理学意见会非常有帮助”时，你却说：“好的，太棒了，谢谢。请做一个转诊。”这可能是最让我……不是被激怒，没那么严重，但比什么都更让我感到沮丧。是的，我认为这很棘手，当然在社区服务中，我工作过的地方，你不能
So, you know, observe, be helpful to the team. So one of the things I've always done is occasionally make coffee so that absolutely everybody in the team is part of that rotor. No one is above going and making coffee for everybody else and that uh helps uh bonding um so again depending on how the kind of mdt meetings are organized um usually patients will be brought into those meetings and i think it works really well if right from the beginning as an assistant psychologist you say oh you know would you like me to go and get the patient rather than relying on on one person to do that and also I think understanding what the the model of of the
直接上手。但当你在住院病房，而且大家都在那里时，你知道，感觉你可以更快地走到前台，你知道，在地面上提供支持，而不需要额外的表格。就是这样。是的，我的意思是，每个人都有时间压力，我并不是说任何一个专业群体比其他群体承受的时间压力小，但特别是对于护士和医生，你不断地重新确定优先级。我认为这在心理学中发生得较少。你通常能够，你有奢侈的条件，能够处理待办事项清单，而不必不断地把事情……我必须把这个推迟，把那个提前。
psychology input to the team is is it it a totally integrated approach? Are you there every week for every MDT meeting or ward round? Every CPA, are you there on that ward and it's your ward? Or is it more of a kind of referral model? And if it's a referral model and you're just going to occasional ones, then that's fine to then ask for referrals. But if you're in part of an integrated team, then there's nothing worse than if somebody in the team is saying it would be really helpful to have a psychology opinion on this to then say, all right, great, thank you. Can you do a do a referral please it is probably the thing that gets me uh not irritated it's not as strong as that but just frustrated more than more than anything else yeah i think it's tricky certainly in community services where i've worked you kind of can't
至少这是我的印象。如果我在这方面完全错了，请告诉我，但这是我的印象。所以事情的紧迫感有时感觉比护理和医学背景的人要多。我认为意识到这一点真的很重要。是的，我认为即使从我和你一起工作的时候算起，对非合格心理学家的期望也已经高得离谱了。所以我当时没有自己的病例。
launch in straight away um but when you're on an inpatient ward and you're all there anyway you know it feels like you can come to the fore a little bit more quickly you know and and um yeah support on the ground um without additional forms that's it yeah i mean um so being aware of um i mean everybody is time pressured i'm not saying saying that any one professional group is less time pressure than any other, but particularly for nurses and doctors, you're constantly reprioritizing. And that is something that happens less, I think, in psychology. You're often able, you have a luxury of being able to kind of work through a kind of a to-do list without constantly having to put things, I've got to move this one forward and that one back.
我主要是支持心理学家和心理学职能，但也支持MDT。所以，你知道，我可能偶尔做一点神经心理学方面的工作，我在做，你知道，监测和记录所有性不当行为，以及，你知道，攻击行为，并为查房等汇报这些情况，但我没有自己的病例。然而，事实上，在我作为一名有抱负的心理学家的这段时间里，人们也被鼓励拥有自己的病例。而且人们工作，你知道，有时甚至高达80%、90%的全职等效时间是面对面的客户时间。这是一个巨大的压力，这是一个巨大的变化，而且
At least that's my impression. Tell me if I'm completely wrong on that, but that's my impression. And so the kind of the urgency of things sometimes feels more than people from nursing and medical backgrounds. And just being aware of that really, I think, is important. Yeah, I think even since when I was working alongside you, the expectations on unqualified psychologists has gone through the roof. So I didn't hold my own caseload when I was working with you.
助理心理学家被要求承担的风险和责任水平，在这些时代，你知道，在这些时代，我成长于那种责任中，而我们要求得更多、更快，我认为这让你没有多少空间去玩耍，也没有多少空间去犯那些错误，并通过观察别人做这些事来学习，因为你身上的压力更大了。你知道，就像你说的，进入一个角色并成长起来很好，但实际上很多有抱负的心理学家发现他们被，你知道，被外包，被放在生产线上，几乎从第一天起就被期望表现出色，这非常困难。好吧，这听起来确实像是被扔进了深水区。我的感觉是，这就是我作为一名医生学习的方式，我认为大多数其他人，
I was very much to support the psychologist and the psychology functions but also the MDT so you know I might have done the odd bit of neuropsych here and there I was doing you know the monitoring and the recording of all of the sexually inappropriate behaviors and the you know the aggression and reporting on those for the ward rounds and things but I didn't hold my own caseload. Whereas actually, what's happened in the time since I was an aspiring psychologist is that people are being encouraged to hold their own caseloads as well. And people are working, you know, sometimes even as much as, you know, 80, 90% of their whole time equivalent hours are face to face client times. And that is, that's a big pressure it's a big change and
你知道，学习那种古老的“看一个，做一个，教一个”的格言。你观察一次手术，然后你就被期望能够自己做。一旦你做了一个，你就被期望教别人怎么做。我不认为这是对的。但当然，你的学习速度比你从一开始就非常谨慎并花大量时间观察要快得多。你从实践中学到的东西比从观察别人做中学到的要多得多。所以，我的意思是，你说这些很有趣。我可能没有意识到发生了这种变化。所以这很艰难，但这绝对会，你知道，
the level of even the level of risk and responsibility that aspiring psychologists are being asked to hold these times you know in these times I grew into that responsibility and we're asking a lot more a lot sooner I think which gives you less room for a little bit of playfulness and less room to you know to make those mistakes and to learn by watching other people do it because there's more pressure on you you know like you said it's nice to come in and grow into a role but actually a lot of aspiring psychologists are finding that they're kind of being you know farmed out and put on the production line and expected to perform almost from day one and it's it's very difficult okay that really does sound like being thrown in at the deep end and um my sense is that uh that that is that is how i learned as a doctor uh and i think most other
帮助人们更快地决定他们是否选择了正确的职业，以及它是否适合他们。而且确实存在这种情况，不是吗？作为一名心理健康专业人士，我们的职业中存在倦怠，特别是在疫情期间，你知道，因为当有病人需要去住院部支持时，没有居家办公这回事。这非常困难。你在职业生涯中对倦怠的体验如何？以及如何支持和培养团队成员以试图减少倦怠？是的，我认为这非常重要，而且一直非常非常艰难。我的意思是，正如我所说，我目前的工作是在一个康复中心。我们一直在努力帮助人们重新融入社区。然后试图在
people you know learn that the old kind of maxim of see one, do one, teach one. You see some procedure once, you're then expected to be able to do it yourself. And then once you've done one, you're expected to teach everybody else how to do it. And I don't think that's right. But certainly your pace of learning is much more than if you start off very cautiously and spend a lot of time observing. You're going to learn an awful lot more from doing than you are from watching someone else do. So, I mean, it's interesting that you're saying that. I perhaps hadn't realized that there'd been that change. So it's tough, but it will definitely, you know,
他们实际上不被允许离开医院时做到这一点，你知道，有国家指导方针，然后是当地的公共卫生指导方针，说：“实际上，你是一家医院，因此你的病人不允许外出。”这种情况持续了几个月。这对病人来说非常艰难。他们在应对方面做得非常出色。但这对员工来说也很艰难，因为这意味着他们必须不断地思考新的事情来做，以防止人们感到无聊，并试图，你知道，重现如果他们在社区中会做的一些事情。
help people decide more quickly if they're in the right career and if it suits them. And there is that, isn't there? There is burnout in our profession as a mental health professional, especially during the pandemic, you know, because there wasn't any working from home when there's patients to go in and support who are living in inpatient units it's very difficult how's your experience of burnout been in the profession and how to support and nurture members of the team to try to reduce burnout yeah I think it is very important um and it has been very very tough I mean my my current job as I say is a rehab unit. And we're trying to, all the time, help people become reintegrated into the community. And to then try and do that
所以我们举办了大约一百万零一次烧烤之类的活动，你知道，只是试图保持新鲜感是一个真正的挑战。但我认为倦怠通常是一个重要的问题，人们确实在谈论它，但往往有点不愿意谈论他们自己的问题。我在自己的职业生涯中也确实遇到过困难，有时情况变得非常艰难，你需要能够与某人交谈，如果你觉得事情在堆积，如果你不喜欢你的工作，如果你，你知道，你早上醒来只是想：“哦，天哪，我不能，我不想去，我无法面对它。”那么这就是一个问题，你需要谈论它。
when they were literally were not allowed outside the hospital, the kind of, there was the national guidelines and then the local public health guidelines that said, actually, you're a hospital, therefore your patients aren't allowed out. And that was for months on end. And it was very tough for the patients. Absolutely amazingly well in coping with that. But it was also tough on staff because it meant that they were having to be constantly thinking of new things to do to stop people getting bored and to try and you know recreate some of the things that they would be doing if they were in the community
而且这些事情通常有解决方案。可能，你知道，换个环境，换个团队。我的意思是，我认为我们都很幸运，我们曾与很棒的团队和很棒的团队成员一起工作。但有时团队运作得不是很好。如果你身处其中一个，我们称之为“有毒团队”，它们确实存在。这很可怕。有时你能做的唯一事情就是尽快离开，或者至少限制你对
so we had about a million and one barbecues and things and you know just trying to keep fresh was a real challenge but I think burnout generally is is an important issue um it's people do talk about it but uh often slightly reluctant to talk about their own problems I've certainly had problems in my own career at times where things got very difficult and uh you need to be able to talk to someone if if you feel things building up, if you're not enjoying your work, if you, you know, you kind of wake up in the morning and just think, oh, God, I can't, I don't want to go in, I can't face it, then that's a problem and you need to talk about that.
这种毒性的接触。所以绝对要和你的主管谈谈，对事情保持开放和诚实。诚实永远是最好的政策。你知道，人们担心如果我有点担心或者听起来像是在抱怨，那么我可能得不到好的推荐信，但我觉得诚实要好得多，而且要处理问题。你知道，你可能会遇到欺凌，你可能会遇到不适当的关注，各种各样的问题都可能出现，你必须处理它。我认为你必须处理它。我认为你必须处理它。是的，我真的很喜欢这个想法，关于思考也许不是我的问题，你知道，也许我没问题。
And there's usually resolutions to these things. And it may be that, you know, a change of scene, a change of team. I mean, I think we're both lucky that we've worked with great teams and great team members. But sometimes teams don't function very well. And if you're in one of these, let's call it a toxic team, they do exist. It's horrible. And sometimes the only thing you can do is get out of that as quickly as possible or at least limit your kind of
也许问题在于这里的环境。也许这是一个有毒的团队。人们经常对我说：“嗯，我有点担心我的简历上只有一份六个月或四个月的工作，这看起来怎么样？”就像，实际上，不，你是金鹅。你必须照顾好你自己。如果这不适合你，说“不”是可以的，说“实际上，我要去别的地方，因为这对我来说不合适”是可以的。这不是我，你知道，就像你对待人的价值观一样，我不认为这样对待人是可以的。
exposure to the toxicity so absolutely talking to your supervisor and being kind of open and honest about things honesty is always the best policy you know people worry though if I kind of worry or sound like I'm moaning then I might not get a good reference but it's far better to be honest I think and and deal with with problems you know that you can get you can get bullying you can get inappropriate attention all sorts of issues can arise and and you have to deal with it I think you have to deal with it. I think you have to deal with it. Yeah, I love that idea actually about thinking about maybe it's not me, you know, maybe I'm okay.
我要用我的脚投票，你知道，我要用我的声音。如果说“不”没有带来改变，你可以获得授权，你可以做出不同的选择去别的地方。是的，绝对是这样。而且这很棘手。我认为这可能，嗯，在某些方面，在你的职业生涯末期或者一旦你有了几年的经验，这会稍微容易一些，因为你有一些经验可以借鉴。在你的职业生涯开始时，很难说：“实际上，这对我来说根本行不通。”
Maybe the problem is the environment here. Maybe this is a toxic team. And people often say to me, well, I'm a bit worried about just having like a six-month post or a four-month post on my CV and how that looks. And it's like, actually, no, you're the golden goose. You have to look after you. And if this isn't a good fit for you, it's okay to say no, it's okay to say actually, I'm going elsewhere, because this is not okay for me. This is not how I, you know, like your values of how to treat people. This is not how I think it's okay to treat people.
但是，你知道，相信你自己，是的，我会说跟随你的直觉。如果当你去上班时感觉很糟糕，那是不正常的。那是不对的，你不应该忍受它。绝对是这样。我不得不说，和你一起工作并不是一个有毒的环境。我离开圣安德鲁斯对我来说真的很困难，从一个非常支持、非常团结、非常庞大和广泛的团队，到后来去NHS的一个非常小的地方，我是唯一的助理，只有一个合格的法医心理学家，那是一个非常小的医疗建筑，不可能更不同了。当我离开时，我真的很怀念你们所有人，你知道，在你的职业生涯中建立不同的工作组合仍然很重要，但是，嗯，是的，很难复制你们所提供的经验和培养，还有非常好的员工聚会。很高兴你喜欢那些。是的，不，圣安德鲁斯，我会说，在你在那里的那段时间里，大部分时间都是一个非常棒的工作场所，我知道它帮助许多心理学家走向了更大更好的地方。这是一个做研究的好地方，只是迈出了那些第一步，你知道，让你的简历上不仅仅有临床工作。参与研究非常重要，我目前在圣马修斯医疗中心（St Matthew's Healthcare）的职位，
And I'm going to vote with my feet, you know, I'm going to use my voice. And if saying no is not making a difference, you can be empowered and you can make different choices to go elsewhere. Yeah, absolutely. And it is tricky. I think it's maybe, well, in some ways it's slightly easier towards the end of your career or once you've had a few years under your belt because you've got some experience to draw on, at the start of your career, it's very hard to say, actually, this just is not working for me.
这是我一直在尝试做的事情之一，就是让并鼓励助理心理学家参与非常简单的小型研究项目。我的意思是，它不必是什么巨大的国际合作研究，只是，你知道，一个病例报告，把那个做成海报，或者写一份审计，所有这些事情只会让你的简历更丰富。它也确实有助于建立关系，而且，无论如何，我是一个研究的忠实信徒，研究确实带来了帮助你思考任何事情的优势。显然，如果你在写一篇论文，它将是关于那个特定的主题，但我认为你在职业生涯中处理任何主题的方式都很重要。是的，绝对是这样。你知道，研究是如此
But, you know, trust yourself and, yeah, follow your instincts is what I would say. And if it just feels horrible when you go to work, that is not normal. It's not right and you shouldn't put up with it absolutely i'll have to say working with you was not a toxic environment i really leaving leaving um st andrews was really difficult for me from a really supportive really cohesive really big and broad team um to then going somewhere very much smaller in the NHS, where I was the only assistant, there was one qualified forensic psychologist, it couldn't have been, you know, tiny little healthcare building couldn't have been more different. And I really mourned for all of you when I left, you know, it's still it's important to build different portfolios of your
重要，它是对有抱负的心理学家来说的关键方面之一，而且，你知道，你在表格上会因为研究获得单独的分数。所以我做的第一项已发表的研究是在圣安德鲁斯，如果约斯顿医生，正如你当时那样，你知道，教授曾要求我参与，我会毫不犹豫地答应。我不敢相信我没有问你。我一直在问。我已经为你写好了。但这是优势之一。你知道，你可以接近人们并说：“你需要写这份研究的帮助吗？”因为那样你的名字就会出现在论文上，这太棒了。太棒了。而且研究对现在很有用，但这很好地引出了对话的下一个领域，
work across the across your career but um yeah it's really difficult hard to replicate what what you guys are offering in terms of experience and nurturance as well and really good staff parties glad you enjoyed those yeah no St Andrews I would say um at the time you were there most of the time that I was there was a fantastic place to work uh and I know that it helped many kind of psychologists go on to bigger and better things. It was a great place to do research and just make those kind of first footsteps towards, you know, just having a bit more on your cv than just clinical work getting involved in research is is so important and my current uh post at St Matthew's Healthcare
即反思也很重要，这有助于我们了解过去，了解人们之前对心理健康的假设。这确实也是你的一个专业兴趣领域。你想告诉我们一点关于为什么以及我在说什么吗？是的，这是一个非常好的引子。非常感谢。是的。所以我一直对精神病学史很感兴趣。我想我的第一篇论文实际上就是一篇精神病学史论文。我一直认为，对现在的心理健康问题和诊断的想法有一个全面的了解是很重要的。我们必须了解这些想法是如何随着时间的推移而演变的。对于一些疾病，它一直追溯到古希腊和古埃及以及
um that's one of the things that I've been trying to do is is get uh and encourage uh assistant psychologists to to be involved in very simple little research projects i mean it doesn't have to be some massive international collaboration study just you know a case report um getting that done as a poster um or uh kind of writing up an audit all those kind of things just gives you a bit more on your cv it also yeah helps helps build relationships and um however um i'm a great believer in research and and and the the advantages really that research brings to to helping you think about about anything really um obviously if you're writing a paper it will be about that particular topic but it's how you approach any topic um in in your career is important i think yeah absolutely and you know research is so
早期的中国和印度。所以它们对某些精神疾病有着非常非常非常悠久的根源，而其他的则是非常现代的。除非你对这一点有所了解，否则我认为很难完全掌握诊断的重要性，以及为什么词汇很重要。所以，正如我所说，我一生都对这一点感兴趣。就在过去的六个月里，我开了一个关于心理健康史的YouTube频道。如果我说实话，如果不是因为我儿子在技术方面提供的帮助，我可能不会做这件事。但到目前为止，我们已经发布了，我想是九个视频，涵盖了广泛的心理健康史主题。它们非常不寻常。
important it's one of the key aspects for aspiring psychologists and it's you know you get separate points on your forms um for research so i did my first piece of published research was at st andrews and if dr yorston as you were at time, you know, professor had asked me to get involved, I'd have snapped your hand off. I can't believe I didn't ask you. I'm always asking. I've written it up for you. But this is one of the advantages. You know, you can approach people and say, do you need any help with writing up this research? Because then you get your name on a paper, which is amazing. Amazing. And research is useful for the now but what leads us on quite nicely to the next area
我认为看看外面的其他视频，我们绝对是在努力让它们变得非常学术。所以有很多对论文的引用，在视频的“关于”部分，我确实包含了一种学术参考列表。所以它们旨在让公众能够理解，但我认为对在心理健康领域工作的人来说特别有意义。嗯，到目前为止我已经看了两个，老实说觉得它们非常有趣。我认为拥有背后的理论非常有用，而且是来自专家，来自一个在现代背景下理解它并能以一种非常相关的方式描绘它的人。这真的很独特。是的，我认为它们相当不错。而且就观看人数而言，
of conversation is it's really useful to reflect upon as well and to help us learn about what went before us and what people's previous assumptions were about mental health and this is really a specialist area of interest for you as well do you want to tell us a little bit about why and what I'm talking about yes that's a very nice lead in. Thank you very much. Yeah. So I've always been interested in the history of psychiatry. I think my very first paper actually was a history of psychiatry paper. And I just always believed that it's important to have a full understanding of what ideas about mental health problems and diagnoses are now. We have to understand how those ideas have evolved over time. And for some disorders, it goes right back to ancient Greece and ancient Egypt and
有趣的是，你知道，它正在增长。而且看看外面一些关于非常相似主题范围的其他视频，你会发现有些人真的只是几乎逐字逐句地读出了维基百科的条目。这没关系。这通常也是我的起点。如果这是一个我不了解的主题，那通常是我的起点。但我一定会尝试增加更多的背景。而且我总是会尝试谈论想法是如何随着时间的推移而改变的。
early China and India. So they're very very very long route to some of the mental disorders others are very modern and unless you you have some understanding about that it's very difficult I think to to to fully grasp the importance of you know of diagnosis and and why words are important. So, as I say, I've been doing interest in that all my life. Just in the last six months, I have started a YouTube channel on the history of mental health. If I'm honest, I probably wouldn't have done it if it hadn't been for the help of my son doing all the technical stuff. But we've so far put out, I think it's nine videos on a wide range of history of mental health topics. And they're quite unusual.
早期中国和印度。因此，它们对某些精神障碍的追溯非常非常久远，而另一些则是非常现代的。除非你对此有所了解，否则我认为很难完全理解诊断的重要性，以及为什么词汇如此重要。正如我所说，我一生都对此很感兴趣。就在过去六个月里，我开通了一个关于心理健康史的YouTube频道。老实说，如果不是我儿子在技术方面提供的帮助，我可能不会去做这件事。但到目前为止，我们已经发布了大约九个视频，涵盖了广泛的心理健康历史主题。它们相当独特。
I think looking at other videos out there, we're definitely trying to aim for them being quite academic. So there's lots of references to papers and in the kind of the about section of the videos, I do include a kind of academic reference list. So they are meant to be understandable to the general public, but to be of particular interest, I think, to people working in mental health. Well, I've watched two of them so far and honestly find them really interesting. I think it's really useful to have the theory behind it, but from an expert as well, from someone that gets it in the modern context and can portray it in a really relatable way. It's really unique. Yeah, I think they're quite good. And in terms of kind of viewing figures,
我认为看看其他的视频，我们确实试图让它们保持相当学术的风格。所以视频中有很多对论文的引用，在视频的简介部分，我也包含了一份学术参考书目。因此，它们旨在让公众能够理解，但我认为对从事心理健康工作的人来说尤其有意义。嗯，到目前为止我已经看了两个，老实说我觉得它们非常有趣。我认为了解其背后的理论非常有用，而且是由专家，即那些在现代背景下理解并能以非常平易近人的方式呈现出来的人来讲解，这真的很独特。是的，我觉得它们相当不错。至于观看数据，
it's interesting that, you know, it's building. And also just looking at some of the other videos out there on very similar ranges of topics, some of them you kind of realise that this person has really just read out a Wikipedia entry, almost word for word. And that's okay. And that's often where I start. If it's a topic I don't know much about, that's usually my starting point. But I will definitely try and add a bit more context. And what I will always try and do is talk about how ideas have changed over time.
有趣的是，你知道，它正在增长。而且看看其他关于非常相似主题的视频，你会发现有些人真的只是逐字逐句地读了维基百科的条目。这没关系。这通常也是我的起点。如果是一个我不太了解的主题，那通常是我的切入点。但我一定会尝试增加更多的背景信息。我总是会尝试讨论这些观点是如何随时间演变的。
And that's particularly interesting, I think, for more recent history. So I've done a couple of videos on one in particular, I think, Rosemary Kennedy, the sister of President Kennedy. And she had probably a kind of mild learning disability, might even not have been below the kind of diagnostic threshold if she was formally tested. But at the time, there was huge stigma associated with that and some you know terrible old-fashioned phrases that we you know it's really hard to speak them out loud nowadays feeble-mindedness morons all this kind of terminology was was in the medical and psychological literature there were people writing papers about this um and suggesting that uh they should be compulsorily sterilized. And in the US, there were 60,000 people were sterilized because they were thought to be unfit for breeding.
我认为这对于近代史来说尤其有趣。我做过几个关于特定人物的视频，比如肯尼迪总统的妹妹罗斯玛丽·肯尼迪。她可能有一种轻微的学习障碍，如果进行正式测试，甚至可能达不到诊断阈值。但在当时，这伴随着巨大的耻辱感，还有一些我们现在很难说出口的陈旧词汇，比如“低能”、“白痴”等等。这些术语出现在医学和心理学文献中，有人写论文建议对他们进行强制绝育。在美国，有6万人因为被认为不适合生育而遭到绝育。
And obviously, that went to its furthest extreme in Germany, where people with mental illness, mental and learning disability were killed, were murdered. Thousands of them, 300,000. So it's important to know. So that's just about within living memory. 1930s, obviously the war, the war period, there are fewer and fewer people around that actually remember that, but the kind of folk memory, if you like, of ideas and stigma lives on. And, you know, even within my career, I can see changes in the way mentally ill people have been regarded,
显然，这种情况在德国达到了极端，患有精神疾病、精神和学习障碍的人被杀害了。成千上万的人，多达30万人。所以了解这一点很重要。这几乎还在人们的记忆中。20世纪30年代，显然还有战争时期，记得这些事的人越来越少了，但关于这些观念和耻辱的“民间记忆”依然存在。而且，即使在我的职业生涯中，我也能看到人们对待精神病患者的方式发生了变化，
the way psychiatry is, you know, viewed by other members of the medical profession. And if I'm honest, you know, I probably would have shared some of those ideas at medical schools, like, who wants to be a psychiatrist? You know, that's terrible you know you never do anything very much you never cure anyone um would have been the kind of rhetoric back in the the 1980s and uh it's been uh you know over the last 30 40 years there has been a gradual move a gradual acceptance that the mental illness isn't something to be ashamed of. And I think, you know, particularly in maybe in the last 10 years, we're gradually moving towards this greater acceptance, but there's still a long way to go. There's still a lot of those ideas that were still there, you know, in the 30s, 40s, 50s. They're still there, they still affect people's thinking. Thank you you it's so
精神病学在医学界其他成员眼中的看法也变了。老实说，在医学院时，我可能也分享过那些想法，比如“谁想当精神科医生啊？那太糟糕了，你永远做不了什么，也治不好任何人”。这大概是20世纪80年代的论调。在过去的30到40年里，人们逐渐达成了一种共识，即精神疾病并不是什么可耻的事情。我认为，特别是在过去10年里，我们正逐渐走向更大的包容，但仍有很长的路要走。那些存在于30、40、50年代的观念依然存在，它们仍然影响着人们的思维。
interesting and i love the breadth and the depth of your experience which i think is what your competition do not have um because you know you've earned your stripes absolutely and there's something to be said about aspiring psychologists learning that breadth and that depth as well isn't it and learning about the importance of the theory. Absolutely, yeah. So, you know, one of the things that a lot of assistant psychologists talk about is diagnosis. And obviously that's not necessarily a word that is the right word for psychology, but it is the way doctors work and have done for probably 2000 years. So you've got to at least understand what a diagnosis is. And sometimes I get asked
非常有趣，我喜欢你经验的广度和深度，我认为这是你的竞争对手所不具备的，因为你确实是靠实力赢得了尊重。对于有抱负的心理学家来说，学习这种广度和深度，以及了解理论的重要性，也是很有意义的，不是吗？绝对是。所以，很多助理心理学家谈论的一个话题就是诊断。显然，这不一定是心理学的正确用词，但这是医生工作的方式，而且可能已经持续了2000年。所以你至少得了解什么是诊断。有时我会被问到
questions like, what is the official diagnosis? And that one always prompts a little bit of discussion from me as I say, well, you know, a diagnosis is just an opinion. And even if we say, well, they fit the criteria of DSM or ICD-10, those are just our current ideas on what the criteria should be. And those have changed over time. They've changed, you know, over the last 50 years and certainly over longer periods of history so so a formulation actually is a more valid individualized way of thinking about a person but everyone's always interested in diagnoses so you have to to fit your uh you'll be willing to at least accommodate a diagnosis in in formulations yeah i mean diagnosis is really useful because it you know like you said it gives us an
诸如“官方诊断是什么？”之类的问题。这总是会引发我的一点讨论，我会说，诊断只是一个观点。即使我们说他们符合DSM或ICD-10的标准，那也只是我们目前对标准应该是什么样子的想法。这些标准随着时间而改变。它们在过去50年里发生了变化，在更长的历史时期里更是如此。所以，个案概念化（formulation）实际上是一种更有效、更个性化的思考人的方式。但每个人都对诊断感兴趣，所以你必须愿意在概念化中至少容纳诊断。是的，我的意思是诊断确实很有用，因为它就像你说的，它给了我们
understanding of how best to understand someone's difficulties and what might be a robust evidence based treatment plan but it doesn't define somebody no and that's the that's the big downside obviously of of diagnoses um and uh it it puts people into boxes and we're dealing with individuals and uh so whilst i would always uh have a diagnosis for a patient you know i also make sure that i have a lot of information on their early development, their pre-mortem personality, so that, you know, you're saying, well, this is the diagnosis, but then this is the individual with this diagnosis and how it has affected them. Yeah, I think it's really useful to discuss with people as well what their diagnosis means and how they feel about it. So I work a lot
一种了解如何最好地理解某人困难的方法，以及什么是稳健的、基于证据的治疗计划，但它并不能定义一个人。当然，这是诊断的一大弊端，它把人框住了，而我们面对的是个体。所以，虽然我会为病人提供诊断，但我也会确保掌握他们早期发展、病前人格的大量信息，这样你就可以说，这是诊断，但这是患有此诊断的个体，以及它如何影响了他们。是的，我认为与人们讨论他们的诊断意味着什么以及他们的感受也非常有用。所以我做了很多
with developmental trauma, I should say people who have had developmental trauma experiences and a lot of them are diagnosed with borderline personality disorder or emotionally unstable personality disorder and they really aren't okay with that because they've already been through awful awful things you know pretty much from the point that they were conceived. So then to be labelled with EUPD feels like a real kick in the guts. And so it's a useful conversation to have. Absolutely, yes. So I always discuss diagnosis with patients, whether they remember it, whether they want to remember it is another thing entirely. But something as incendiary as EUPD is such an important diagnosis. But also, you know, helping patients understand that, you know, what that actually says to other people who will be
关于发展性创伤的工作，我想说的是，那些有发展性创伤经历的人，很多人被诊断为边缘性人格障碍或情绪不稳定型人格障碍，他们对此真的无法接受，因为他们从受孕那一刻起就经历过可怕的事情。所以被贴上EUPD（情绪不稳定型人格障碍）的标签感觉就像是对他们沉重的打击。所以这是一个有用的对话。绝对是。所以我总是和病人讨论诊断，至于他们是否记得，是否想记得，那是另一回事。但像EUPD这样具有煽动性的诊断是非常重要的。同时，也要帮助病人理解，这实际上对其他人意味着什么，因为他们会
reading that diagnosis. And sadly, it's, you know, it's not going to, you know, people are going to think oh right uh difficult patient um and they and i think it's useful for patients to know that that diagnoses are going to evoke emotional responses in in other health care professionals definitely i have loved speaking with you today and i honestly feel like i could speak to you all day um but we tried to keep these episodes at about 30 minutes so we're going to need to draw it to a close have you got any final points or kind of um questions or observations that you want to make yeah no just really um you know work hard at becoming part of the the team as i say make the coffee go and get the patients um but you will
阅读那个诊断。遗憾的是，人们会想“哦，是个难缠的病人”。我认为让病人知道诊断会引起其他医疗专业人员的情绪反应是很有用的。今天和你交谈我非常开心，老实说我觉得我可以和你聊一整天，但我们尽量把这些剧集控制在30分钟左右，所以我们需要结束了。你还有什么最后的观点、问题或观察想提吗？没有了，只是真的要努力成为团队的一员，就像我说的，去泡咖啡，去接病人，但你也会
also sometimes make the coffee you know absolutely no definitely not so um you know if there's any psychiatrist listening to this then do not expect people to make coffee for you be willing to go and make it so it's it's although usually that the psychiatrist is the uh the unelected leader of the team, there's no real reason for that. There's no management responsibility that says, oh, the doctor has to be in charge. But that's just the way most teams work, not every team, but the way most teams work. being aware of that and working with it and with the uh being aware of the kind of the history of how psychiatry psychology and other professions have developed and all work together i love it it's been such an interesting episode and been a pleasure to speak to you how can people um get um get connected with you where where are you at with your youtube channel youtube search putting
有时也要泡咖啡，你知道的。绝对不是。所以，如果有任何精神科医生在听这个节目，不要指望别人为你泡咖啡，要愿意自己去泡。虽然通常精神科医生是团队中非选举产生的领导者，但这并没有真正的理由。没有管理职责规定医生必须负责。但这只是大多数团队运作的方式，不是每个团队，但大多数团队是这样。意识到这一点并与之合作，同时意识到精神病学、心理学和其他专业是如何发展并共同工作的历史。我喜欢这个，这真是一个有趣的剧集，和你交谈很愉快。人们如何与你联系？你的YouTube频道在哪里？搜索
professor graham yorston or history of mental Health that will lead to my videos and that's probably the easiest way to get hold of me. I think my son's even opened a TikTok one for me but I don't really know what's on that yet, I don't really understand TikTok but I'm not doing any dancing, safe with that one. So that's probably the easiest place to see me. Lovely. Let's have a practice. What should people do when they get to your channel? Oh, yes, they should. Now, what is it called again? Subscribe. Yeah, so subscribe.
Graham Yorston教授或“心理健康史”，那会引导到我的视频，这可能是找到我最简单的方法。我想我儿子甚至为我开了一个TikTok账号，但我还不知道上面有什么，我不太懂TikTok，但我不会跳舞，那个账号很安全。所以那可能是找到我最简单的地方。太好了。让我们练习一下。人们进入你的频道时应该做什么？哦，是的，他们应该……现在它叫什么来着？订阅。是的，所以订阅。
And like. And like. And comment. So comment is important. One of the things you do have to be aware of, though, is you have to develop a thick skin. So there's overwhelmingly positive comments so far, but but by gum there's a few absolutely horrible ones so you have to learn to kind of uh not focus on those which is you know it's important in life to be able to do that
还有点赞。还有点赞。还有评论。所以评论很重要。不过，有一件事你必须意识到，那就是你必须脸皮厚一点。到目前为止，评论绝大多数是积极的，但天哪，也有一些绝对糟糕的评论，所以你必须学会不要关注那些，这在生活中是很重要的。
so like subscribe and click on the notification so that when the new ones come out it goes you somehow know about it miraculously where the wonder of technology i love that honestly do it do and do it for this channel as well because this one's good too it's been an absolute pleasure to reconnect with you and wishing you all the best with your youtube channel and beyond and book writing and all of those good things are going to be coming imminently thank you so much for joining me. And thank you for inviting me. It's been a pleasure. Hello, my name is Veronika Kosova. I live in Edinburgh, and I just graduated with a Master's in Psychology of Mental Health. Marion recommended me the Clinical Psychologist Collective when I was
所以点赞、订阅并点击通知，这样当新视频发布时，你就能奇迹般地知道。科技的奇迹，我喜欢这个。老实说，一定要做，也要为这个频道做，因为这个频道也很好。能和你重新联系真是太高兴了，祝你的YouTube频道、写作以及所有即将到来的好事一切顺利。非常感谢你加入我。也谢谢你邀请我。这是我的荣幸。你好，我叫Veronika Kosova。我住在爱丁堡，刚获得了心理健康心理学硕士学位。Marion在我进行LinkedIn社交时向我推荐了“临床心理学家集体”（Clinical Psychologist Collective），我必须说我喜欢它。它是独一无二的。
networking on LinkedIn, and I must say I love it. It is one of a kind. It's like a window into the lives of people on the path of becoming a psychologist. The stories are unique, honest and filled with a kind of intangible wisdom only personal storytelling can uncover. A common thread in the stories I valued most was to be compassionate not only with others but with myself too. Also not fixating on becoming a psychologist but enjoying life, grow and the final results will come as a byproduct. Marianne thank you for taking the time to correlate all the stories. The book is a true gem and I think every aspiring psychologist should have a copy on their shelf. Thank you! Then let this be your guide Filled with lessons and experience
它就像一扇窗，让我们看到那些走在成为心理学家道路上的人们的生活。这些故事独特、诚实，充满了只有个人叙述才能揭示的那种无形的智慧。我最看重的故事中的共同点是，不仅要对他人的富有同情心，也要对自己富有同情心。此外，不要执着于成为心理学家，而是享受生活，成长，最终的结果会作为副产品出现。Marianne，谢谢你花时间整理所有的故事。这本书是一块真正的瑰宝，我认为每一位有抱负的心理学家都应该在书架上放一本。谢谢！那么让这成为你的指南，充满经验和教训，
That will help you get qualified So come and take a look It's right here in this book It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective Thank you so much for listening. I really love to connect with you over on socials. LinkedIn is Dr. Marianne Trent.
这将帮助你获得资格。所以来看看吧，就在这本书里。这是“临床心理学家集体”。这是“临床心理学家集体”。非常感谢你的收听。我真的很喜欢在社交媒体上与你联系。LinkedIn是Dr. Marianne Trent。
YouTube is Good Thinking Psychological Services. Facebook is also Good Thinking Psychological Services. Twitter is Good Thinking PS1. Instagram is Dr. Marianne Trent. If TikTok is your jam, I'm also on there too at Dr. Marianne Trent. Being well supported during a psychology application season is so important. We have got one final date planned for a compassionate Q&A, which is going to be taking place on the 9th of May, Monday, the 9th of May at 7.30pm UK time. And that is free to attend. If you would like to watch any of the replays from the three previous episodes then you can do so by going along to good thinking psychological services on youtube
YouTube是Good Thinking Psychological Services。Facebook也是Good Thinking Psychological Services。Twitter是Good Thinking PS1。Instagram是Dr. Marianne Trent。如果TikTok是你的最爱，我也在那里，账号是Dr. Marianne Trent。在心理学申请季得到良好的支持非常重要。我们计划了最后一次同情心问答（Q&A），将于5月9日星期一英国时间晚上7点30分举行。这是免费参加的。如果你想观看之前三集的重播，你可以去YouTube上的Good Thinking Psychological Services频道
and then if you click the playlist compassionate q a you'll be able to find the three previous episodes there hope you will find it useful and as ever, we'd love any feedback you've got on any of our free resources. If you are finding this podcast helpful, please do talk about it on social media, tag me in, tag your friends, do all of those good things. And I will look forward to catching up with you on our next episode, which will be along on Mondays at 6am UK time. Thank you so much. I had to be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner.
然后点击“同情心问答”播放列表，你就能找到之前的三集。希望你觉得有用。一如既往，我们欢迎你对我们任何免费资源提供反馈。如果你觉得这个播客有帮助，请在社交媒体上谈论它，标记我，标记你的朋友，做所有这些好事。我期待在下一集中与你见面，下一集将在英国时间周一早上6点发布。非常感谢。祝你在获得资格的道路上一切顺利。这是Dr. Marianne Trent的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。
I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。有多少种不同的途径可以达到目标让我感到惊讶，成为心理学家没有完美的途径，这让我充满了信心，不再觉得我做错了，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。